joining us now on the phone is Rudy
Guiliani personal attorney for President
Trump speaking with us exclusively after
the release of this recording
mayor Giuliani thank you so much for
checking in with us tonight first of all
your reaction to this tapes release well
I think it's first of all the major
point is it's outrageous that someone
would tape his client surreptitiously
and number two it's also foolhardy for
them to try to kind of yell and scream
and make believe what's on the tape I
agree with you the tape it's a little
bit hard to hear but I assure you that
we listen to it numerous numerous times
and the transcript makes it quite clear
at the end that President Trump says
quote don't pay with cash Cohen dent
interrupts and says no no no I got it
and then you hear distinctly if you're
careful and you slow it down check and
then Cohen follows with no no no and
then quickly cuts off the tape which
indicates exactly where she was saying
that Cohen doesn't want the rest of the
court because it was to expel fitori
from the point of view of the press
there's no way the president is going to
be talking about setting up a
corporation and then using cash unless
you're a complete idiot and he ends
presidents not really there's a moment
tonight on CNN where where Lonny Davis
he kept saying well we are going we're
showing you that what Giuliani claimed
that Michael Cohen was the one who
brought up the issue of cash not his
client Donald Trump we're showing you
with this tape that it was Trump who
brought it up so he seemed to say that
the release of the tape reading was
because of you and what you said well
the fact is that the president does
bring up cash but he says don't pay with
cash and then Cohen says no no no and
the president says check and then Cohen
says I got it point if the president
want the transaction could be memorial
Rudy there was a some concern about the
decision to waive pro
in this case a lot of legal commentators
we just talked to Dershowitz so that's
all that's all well and good that's all
well and good for them to say that but
the reality is that the tape was leaked
not by us nobody believes that
last week we were treated to how we
leaked it was Jay and I were laughing
about Jay Sekulow
this was leaked on us with a very very
scurrilous description of what was on
this day probably by the same people who
are lying on CNN and we had it we had to
correct the record but we have no
problem making this limited release
because it is it is collaborative of the
president's statement now our so are you
still maintaining then tonight that the
recording that was released this evening
is 100% exculpatory toward the president
in his previous statements about this oh
I think your two guests just said that
there's no indication of any crime being
committed on this state and that is
absolutely right so that is why we go
ahead now the the you know what the left
is going to say you know what they do
they've been doing it for months that
the president gave the impression that
he didn't know about any of these
transactions that this was this might
have been happening but he didn't know
about them comment on Air Force One saw
references in in the previous statement
he said I didn't know but it sounds like
he knew that something was being set up
to perhaps buy the rights to this
MacDougal story correct no in fact if
you go back a little further on the
prints because I don't get the whole
thing Cohen says D we need financing and
the president spent wait a second what
for anthing then he asked explain it the
president did not know about this before
this conversation at least with regard
to the transaction that we're talking
about I mean he may have he may or may
not have known about the Dukas claims I
don't know that but he didn't know about
he didn't know about this transaction
this is the conversation in which they
talked about how they're going to buy
the rights and the rights people have to
understand who are watching tonight the
rights to this story from the National
Enquirer the company that owns a
National Enquirer we're never perch
so that transaction did not go through
that's another thing that's absurd about
this what it makes clear is this is at
most an attempt to do something I don't
know of any attempt in this category of
of crime that they're looking at so in
any event I don't think anyone can
suggest that this represents anything
where the president did anything wrong
and that's the reason why we waived it
would we have put it out had it not been
leaked no we would not have put it out
had it not been leaked but it was being
leaked visiting our time under very very
false which false statements being made
about it which even a word they're the
ones you're hearing now were you given
were you giving a heads up Rudy that
this was coming out tonight at all or
was this a surprise to you yes we found
out at six o'clock to staff dinner and
look we've been over the tape over the
weekend about five times what I urged
people to do is just go on and online
listen to your broadcast you play the
tape plenty of three times the third
time you play it'll become clear
I've set dates even longer than Alan
Dershowitz how about 4,000 hours of
mafia people on tapes I know how to
listen to them I know how to transcribe
this tape is crystal clear when you
listen to it I've dealt with much worse
shape than this are you concerned that
there are other recordings out there
between Cohen and the president as a
lawyer as someone who's dealt with
people have been in a lot of trouble
before just like you have Rudy the idea
of a lawyer taping a client is I think
it takes your breath away but you know
are there other tapes that you're aware
of release them yourself today today
someone was leaking from I'm sure their
side it can't be ours that there are 12
tapes of Cohen with the President may
have been avenatti somebody else don't
quote me on that
he's leaked things like there are a lot
more tapes with the President and
durscher which yesterday asked him how
because it would be illegal for him to
have that information and unethical but
in any event there are no other takes
with the president we have all the tapes
in our possession we have transcripts of
all of them
we're comfortable with them and there
are no there are no others now Rudy
you've known Lanny Davis a long time and
like I've known him going back 20 years
during the Clinton saga do you do you
have any thoughts about his decision to
represent Michael Cohen given his long
ties to the Clintons no not at all I
don't have any any any any concerns
about that he's a lawyer you have the
right to represent who we want and
Michael has the right I question the
strategy of doing this of trying to make
a tape say what it doesn't say or if
putting out a tape in which you're kind
of proud of the fact that you're a
lawyer taping your client and then
thinking you could cooperate with the
government you know to cooperate with
the government you got to have
credibility first thing that happens is
this guy's gonna be disbarred
I mean it's ridiculous he's a pariah to
the legal profession there was a moment
tonight on CNN I'm gonna play it for you
Rudy where Chris Cuomo actually asks
about this recording and whether it
might taint the entire substance of it
let's watch listen this recording could
be argued to be fruit of the poisonous
tree that as counsel Michael Cohen
shouldn't have been recording his
counsel his client van Donald J Trump
now President Trump how do you get past
that that this whole thing can't look
good for Cohen cuz he should have never
done it well I'm not gonna shift the
topic it's up to mr. Cohen to explain
why he was taking so he didn't want to
we want to go this is great what have I
ever said it's up to the President to
explain that's just that's just lawyer
on being interviewed by Cuomo and he
throws the ball to his client I mean if
this is crazy representation have you
ever heard of anything like this you put
out a tape of your client you then make
believe it says something it doesn't say
believe me there were three other
versions of this before we got to this
one that we're even worse and the
transcript belies that if you analyze it
have the patience to analyze it don't
become like forget about it and now we
saying we you know give the ball to give
the ball through to my client
so you're Mina's going I don't mean to
harp on the Clinton you know connection
here but it is interesting that Cohen
chooses the longtime confidant booster
defender of the Clintons after
everything that happened during the
campaign to represent him here I mean
was he was he I mean you know this how
this deal goes Rudy was he was Cohen
trying to send some kind of message to
the president you know look out here we
come and you better watch out mean it's
an odd choice of lawyer in my view it's
an odd choice well I don't know I can't
comment on that Laura I don't know it
you know someone will say anything with
like the counsel if I do that I don't
want to do that and I just question the
whole tactic and Lanny's comment tonight
shifting the thing to Co instead of
throwing them on the bus and Rudy
finally here you got to be able to
answer you got to be able to answer via
client or not answer at all and and
finally Rudy on the issue of talking to
Muller special counsel here the reports
came out that you all will talk about
collusion and nothing else
are there any developments on that that
you can tell us tonight oh no I think
we've been distracted the last couple
days and they've been distracted with
the with the they're getting ready for
the metaphor case so I you know we'll
probably get an answer in the next
hopefully next couple of days a week all
right Rudy Giuliani
we really appreciate right doing us
tonight exclusive thank you so much